four months before Steve Jobs planned to
reveal the iPhone to the world he
decided to switch the screen from
plastic to Glass because plastic was too
easily scratched Engineers freaked out
because they didn't have a working glass
prototype that could pass the 1 meter
drop test there was however an American
Glass Square company that had once
prototyped a strong scratch prooof
product dubbed Gorilla Glass but didn't
have a market for IT jobs doubted the
glass was good enough and started
lecturing cing CEO Wendell weeks on
glass was made weeks boldly interjected
as described in Walter ison's book can
you shut up and let me teach you some
science jobs was convinced but week said
his company didn't have the capacity to
make the gorilla glass in its factories
to which jobs said don't be afraid yes
you can do it get your mind around it
you can do it and Corning did do it the
day the iPhone came out job sent weeks
this message we couldn't have done it
without you